No what's it like being a dad and stuff
mmm I watched my daughter play tennis I
think she could be your two kids right
yeah you have a daughter
uh I've been thinking what is love I
read a book about it I read a book about
parenting cuz I was on the roster I was
not on the same page as my wife and I
was kind of like she had read all the
books and I have to say that if you want
to make your kids self-reliant there's
one thing to say well you think you can
parent but you can't unless you [ __ ]
unless you they're people that can help
you I'm flailing if your kid doesn't
want to do something your and your
instinct is to bully them and say no
you're gonna do it because I said so
yeah Thomas doesn't really work it
doesn't foster creativity there's a lot
of different ways you can go about it so
I guess it's been challenging because
I've had to kind of rethink how I so
let's say I'm your daughter
yeah and you say clean your would ask me
to clean my room I would say hey um are
we going to live in this where
everything is all over the place how do
you find things yeah I just like it this
way you do yeah well do you think that
maybe I could help you clean things up
so it's a little better organized so
this way you can find things faster so
we don't have to wait for a long time no
no okay so I'll tell you what in that
case I don't think we're gonna be able
to go to the beach because we just don't
have the time for you to find all your
stuff so I guess the choice is yours but
you can make your own choice oh I try to
do as I track you really good try to
give them it's a choice so when my son
today he couldn't his shirt was trying
it was inside out and he was cold and I
go so so why don't you just take your
shirt and turn it inside I can't
no well you can no I can't I go would
you like me to help you try and then
I'll so so so you could you build sort
of self relief life here's the other
thing but here's the other thing I will
my daughter is really good at tennis
right problem is the I have to resist
the instinct of saying of correcting her
telling or coaching her what the best
thing
father can do is go guy I love watching
you play I just love it and then I'll
say stuff like this I'll talk about her
so so I'll say stuff like this when she
she thinks I'm not that I I don't think
she's listening I go listen man I'm
telling you she can focus the way she
focuses and and when she misses a shot
she doesn't freak out the way I used to
as a kid she just like she's like
nothing and she just goes back to doing
it again nice and I brag about her to
her mother or somebody I talk about her
like she's my hair like she's the hero
so what happens they'll fulfill that
destiny yeah kids do that they don't
human beings have they resist being even
an infant or a toddler when you they
have a spoon and you try to pull out of
the hand they're gonna squeeze harder
human beings want their own serenity
their own their own autonomy I like
using words like serenity autonomy 9g
I'm not worried about her at all I can
just get out in high school though like
them when I school when she goes on a
date let's just give me a scenario and
she comes home from the day with a black
eye what would you do that's not
something I can talk about no but what I
wouldn't know is specifically what you
I'll tell you this I'm ready for it what
what do you mean I'm ready so I so I am
let's see I'm a high school kid a guy I
took your daughter on a day yeah I drop
her off and I punched her eye out oh
yeah right she comes in the house oh
this is a hypothetical yes I don't know
what you're gonna use some I'm already
ready flop all right would you co
confront me dude you're gonna end up
it's gonna be bad for you
like I'm gonna do it alone
I understand that so just verbally
confront me I'm not gonna say anything
you're not gonna say no well but I have
a reason why I'm just gonna show up no I
have a reason why I understand that you
can tell me the knavish she injected
aids in me you can tell me all about it
all better when you're bound and gagged
in my trunk and gornstein hear my
[ __ ] point of view
I would have pretend to be a dad too
so let me see what I can do the
psychological thing okay Gilbert okay oh
it's scenario would you like whatever
senior you're myself what's your name
I'll make it up yeah
the moto that's a bad pretty good it's
closest tomato but it's like the Moto
the Moto yeah the Moto what did holy
[ __ ] - yeah yeah
super - eight he has a disease
he's from the Sudan and he's 78 or
cancer you adopted your dude all right
let me do it again
and what try not to laugh that voice is
very good though and I'm gonna give him
credit for that the second city but okay
Tomoko you did yeah um what wipe your
brooms messy what are you gonna do about
it
oh really um you know it's fine you
don't have to clean it but um you're
just not gonna eat you follow the UFC
dude you can't threaten this target kid
though that doesn't really work yeah but
he'll he's gonna want to eat it dad
I know Child Services yeah well you're
not gonna have a phone okay watch how
you do it yeah so be rude to me watch
honestly I'm gonna say something and I
want you to say [ __ ] you dad
oh he's getting up right now he's
getting up he goes to the bathroom
closes the door what do you do you're
out and you're punching a tree in the
backyard
back then I come back then I come back
about 15 minutes later yeah what's going
on hey um I want to talk to you about
something what that you know when you
said [ __ ] you to me yeah
very disrespectful and if you do that
again I'm just not gonna deal with you
anymore I'm just gonna do the same thing
so we have to talk about how you can be
a little bit more respectful see that's
why you're a good dad
I'm not gonna be able to do it yeah but
I have to read eBooks about it I had to
read books about cuz I used to be like
what did you say what used to be like
this do it again do it again so I say
[ __ ] you again [ __ ] you dad alright
what'd you say to me say it again I dare
you say to go on again Belet for you
okay
why oh you okay the end now and now you
look say now you don't get now you don't
get to do anything and I allow me to
grab your face and get in your face yeah
hard and stand and yell at you and tell
you that you're grounded for the rest of
your life and I'm sending you to
Guantanamo Bay oh cool oh well double
[ __ ] you and the con I mean mom I would
I would I would there we go I would duct
tape your mouth yeah that Rico so that's
what you would do you would walk away
though after reading the books now dude
it's so effective yeah sometimes just
silence just going that's really good
you what you're broken at dot remark
about on stage if there's hecklers yeah
instead of because I one night I was
there was hecklers in the Oh art as a
years ago and I just raised my voice
he goes no next time just whisper cuz in
the room will quiet down to listen to
what you're saying yeah so sometimes
being quiet is the best no no I've never
seen him follow that bug yeah well we
had time was we're now over fifty that's
great what the timing
[Music]